Narrator: In 1923's
"The Ten Commandments,"
the Israelites walk
through the parted Red Sea.
It's actually two separate
shots combined into one.
According to sources at the time,
the first shot was just the actors,
and the second was actually gelatin.
This compositing technique was a precursor
to the blue- and green-screen technology
that has taken over the industry.
Julie Turnock: There's
almost nothing that is
completely unrelated to a previous event.
Narrator: Back before the
widespread use of CGI,
effects artists and
filmmakers did everything
from painting on top of shots
to projecting moving backgrounds
to make the impossible happen.
Here are seven tricks
used in old Hollywood
that still exist in some form today.
CG allows filmmakers to
place people and objects
anywhere they want in a scene,
but it wasn't used in a movie
until 1973's "Westworld."
So how did filmmakers in
the early 1900s do this?
With arguably the
first-ever special effect,
the substitution splice.
A filmmaker would start filming a scene.
Then they'd stop the camera
and start shooting again
from the same position
with a new person or
object added to the frame.
This effect made it seem like something
or someone appeared out of thin air.
Director Georges Méliès
used a substitution splice
in many of his on-screen illusions,
such as this one in 1896's
"The Vanishing Lady."
The trick was also used to
pull off dangerous stunts.
Take a look at 1895's
"The Execution of Mary, Queen of Scots."
To make the monarch's beheading look real,
the actor first knelt
at the chopping block,
then the director stopped filming
and a dummy was placed
where the actor was.
When they resumed filming,
the executioner chopped
off the dummy's head.
By today's standards,
this early form of editing
is pretty noticeable.
Stunt coordinators these
days improve this concept
with camera lock-offs.
Take this moment, when
The Rock's character
gets hit in the face by a motorcycle
in 2016's "Central Intelligence."
To keep the actor safe,
they filmed the shot from
the exact same angle twice.
First they captured a
motorcyclist doing a backflip,
then The Rock's stunt
double being pulled back.
With today's visual effects technology,
the two takes could be
seamlessly combined.
One of the earliest
challenges of animation
was natural movement.
So animators turned to rotoscoping,
first thought up by
Max and Dave Fleischer.
Artists would project
live-action film footage
onto their easel and sketch
over the images frame by frame
so they could mimic real-life movements.
For example, in the 1932
cartoon "Minnie the Moocher,"
the Fleischer brothers gave the characters
eye-popping dance moves
by rotoscoping Cab Calloway.
Nowadays, rotoscoping software
allows for this process
to be used on something much
longer than a short cartoon,
like the TV series "Undone."
And motion-capture tech
is a natural extension
of the Fleischers' work,
with fully realized
mo-cap characters like
Thanos in "Infinity War."
1933's "The Invisible Man" needed to shoot
its invisible lead wearing clothes
so the audience could see him.
How do you create a floating shirt
without today's technology?
Instead of a green screen,
they used a technique called compositing.
In Méliès' time, this could be done
through double exposure.
But James Whale instead
used a compositing method
known as the Williams process.
First, actor Claude Rains
was filmed in black velvet
against a black backdrop.
This created a negative,
allowing every part of
the actor to disappear
except for the parts not covered in black.
They then filmed the
background separately.
These mattes were then printed,
masking off the foreground and background
until the two images were combined.
Creating the right composite images
often involved thinking outside the box,
like that scene from
"The Ten Commandments"
we described earlier.
Because the compositing was done by hand,
it was an imperfect process.
If you watch old movies in
which you can see the edges
around the figures where
they've been composited in,
that means that the
optical printer operator
was short on time.
Oftentimes it's just cheap effects,
because they didn't want
to spend money to do it.
Narrator: Modern compositing
is much smoother.
The black screen used in
1933's "Invisible Man"
has been replaced with today's
blue and green screens,
and elements are filmed
on motion-control cameras
for a more seamless composite,
like in 2020's "The Invisible Man."
They first shot one take of Elisabeth Moss
being attacked by a stand-in
and then a second clean take without them.
Things get a bit more complicated
when it comes to fantasy backgrounds,
like in "The Wizard of Oz."
The filmmakers couldn't just
composite in real footage
for the land of Oz,
and building all the sets from scratch
would have been a difficult task.
So instead they used matte paintings
to paint around the characters.
For this effect, a matte
blocking everything
except the actors was placed
in front of the camera.
The artists later painted the surroundings
on a separate glass matte
before the two images were combined.
So, for example, when Dorothy walks down
the Yellow Brick Road in this shot,
it was actually just the actors
on a set with no backdrop.
The sky, flowers, and mountains
were all painted in after the fact
to make it look like they were headed
towards the Emerald City.
But it's still hard to overcome
the flatness of a painting.
Look at this shot of Orson Welles speaking
in front of a large
crowd in "Citizen Kane."
The painted extras appear
completely lifeless.
Present-day digital
mattes and set extensions
offer a fix to that.
By duplicating tiles of real extras
and adding digital doubles into the mix,
"Ted Lasso" could create
a fully formed stadium
filled with 26,000 fans who could react
directly to the action shot in-camera.
Without today's animation software,
it can be difficult to add realistic
three-dimensional depth
to hand-drawn scenes.
So in the 1930s and '40s,
many animated Disney
classics used an invention
called a multiplane camera.
The camera was attached to
several layers of glass,
each displaying a
different layer of artwork.
Each layer could be
moved at different speeds
and distances from each other.
Because the two-dimensional
drawings were separated
in real three-dimensional space,
they created a parallax effect.
This camera helped add depth
to the forest in "Bambi,"
and it's how filmmakers made
the Evil Queen's
surroundings spin around her
in "Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs."
These days, the multiplane-camera effect
is recreated digitally.
The various layers can be designed
and easily separated on a computer
to create the illusion of depth,
and filmmakers are getting more creative
with how they integrate 3D
assets and trick the eye.
2020's "Wolfwalkers" created
a 3D forest as a guide
to place hand-drawn characters
into dynamic environments.
Even before CG, filmmakers tried to fix
the static nature of painted
mattes and 2D backgrounds.
One solution was rear projection,
which created dynamic moving
backgrounds in real time.
An actor would stand in front of a screen,
and behind that screen,
a projector would play
footage shot elsewhere.
Like this shot from
1938's "Bringing up Baby."
In reality, the two stars and this leopard
were nowhere near each other.
Cary Grant and Katharine
Hepburn were actually driving
in a fake car on a set,
while the leopard was shot separately
and projected behind them on a screen.
Or this plane crash from
1940's "Foreign Correspondent."
Director Alfred Hitchcock
projected real footage
of the sky and ocean through
the cockpit's windows.
But rear projection had its own issues.
Because it was projected from the back,
the lighting and image
looked a lot less realistic.
Plus, it was difficult
to match the lighting
of the real world in the studio.
That's why the background
roads in these driving scenes
from "To Catch a Thief" and
"Dr. No" look so flat today.
Rear projection also
became harder to utilize
as more and more films were shot in color.
The colors are often just a little off.
And they're just off enough
that, especially today,
because, you know, with
digital composites,
you can correct that stuff pretty easily,
but you couldn't at the time.
Narrator: Still, rear projection lives on
through boundary-pushing technologies
used by directors like Stanley
Kubrick and Jon Favreau.
In "2001: A Space Odyssey,"
Kubrick instead placed the projector
in front of the screen
with a light bouncing off a mirror.
This created a stunning
deep focus and perspective
during the Dawn of Man sequence.
You won't see that in a rear projection
or any matte painting.
And LED screens have turned projection
from a cheesy effect to awe-inspiring.
For example, "The Mandalorian"
chose to swap projections
and green screens with LED screens.
You can immediately see how
naturally the light reflects
off the Mandalorian and
Baby Yoda in this shot.
And because the camera actually moves
in sync with the background,
this shot has a natural parallax effect,
just like those multiplane
cameras from decades earlier.
Before monsters and other creatures
could be created with
CG and motion capture,
filmmakers primarily used
stop-motion animation,
but stop motion requires
expensive miniature models and sets,
which often look unnatural
when interacting with the cast.
You can see that from
looking at "King Kong,"
as the claymation Kong
can't truly interact with Fay Wray.
So pioneering stop-motion
animator Ray Harryhausen
thought of Dynamation.
His method combined a range
of visual effects techniques,
from mattes to projection.
To understand how it works,
let's look at this fight scene
between human characters
and a skeleton army
in 1963's "Jason and the Argonauts."
The actors rehearsed their
moves with stuntpeople
who stood in for the skeleton army,
but the scene was actually shot
without the stunt performers
and only with the actors
playing the human characters.
Harryhausen then used stop
motion for the skeleton army.
To match the movements perfectly,
the footage of the actors shadowboxing
was projected behind the animation table
while Harryhausen moved the
skeletons frame by frame.
A camera filmed the skeleton
army through a glass matte,
masking off the shadowboxing actors.
Finally, the shadowboxing
scene and the skeleton scenes
were printed and composited together.
This five-minute sequence
took four and a half months to complete.
But Dynamation's influence
can still be seen
in the blue- and green-suit performers
standing in for characters
that will be created with CG.
In 2019's "Dumbo," a green-suit performer
helped the cast with their sight lines
when interacting with the baby elephant.
And motion capture allows an
actor to play a CG dog on set,
so nobody is guessing
where they have to look.
Looking back at Dynamation's
individual elements,
each effect can seem time-consuming
and outdated on its own,
but it shows how every
technological advancement in cinema
wouldn't exist without
the low-tech experiments
of the industry's past.